[Música]
llegó el momento de repasar la prensa
internacional con rosa pérez más de eeuu
que nos acompaña ya esta mañana en
nuestra mesa de trabajo rosa gracias por
estar como siempre todas las mañanas con
nosotros vamos a empezar esta revista de
prensa con la entrevista que le realiza
el escritor y periodista británico owen
jones a la principal figura la izquierda
en eeuu hablamos de bernie sanders un
texto publicado en 'the guardian' y
también que titula las personas están
cansadas de ser ignoradas mientras los
ricos se vuelven más ricos rosas
buenos días raúl efectivamente y esta
entrevista para este periódico británico
que como bien decía se realiza este
conocido periodista y escritor owen
jones y se enmarca en la visita de
bernie sanders como decías el
considerado el líder de la izquierda
estadounidense pues esta visita al reino
unido- precisamente para apoyar el
movimiento trabajador inof is in off no
en la capital británica bien
precisamente así empieza este artículo
de the gardian que introduce a saunders
presentándolo como decíamos como un
líder de la izquierda diciendo aunque ni
sus candidaturas para 2016 y 2020
tuvieron éxito generaron un movimiento
que revitalizó a la izquierda
estadounidense y la transformó en una
fuerza política importante dentro del
partido demócrata y más allá
precisamente dice unións el hilo
conductor de toda la conversación de lo
que va respondiendo bernie sanders es
dice la política y el discurso de clases
un discurso que durante mucho tiempo
estuvo ausente en eeuu que vendía el
mito pues de la igualdad total y de la
igualdad de oportunidades y precisamente
en este contexto
bernie sanders defiende esta ola
sindical no esta nueva ola sindical que
hemos comentado tantas veces en este
programa en la que dice que están
confluyendo los jóvenes en muchos casos
estudiantes con un movimiento obrero
trabajador digamos más tradicional no y
dice todo esto a pesar de las trabas que
describe bernie sanders y aquí también
hemos comentado de las empresas de las
amenazas de los despidos o de las
amenazas como decíamos de
deslocalización no sanders de hecho
describe este nuevo movimiento en eeuu
de la siguiente forma una lucha
generacional multirracial principalmente
de personas jóvenes
exclusivamente que se enfrentan a un
multimillonario y dice pues los jóvenes
son también digamos una de sus
principales bases de apoyos y señala que
la política de bailén de perdonar la
deuda estudiantil a muchos jóvenes
estudiantes o ex estudiantes estuvo
influenciada dice por sus campañas por
las de sanders porque puse sobre la mesa
que muchas personas estaban descontentas
y querían cambios cambios estructurales
los ahora como de las elecciones de
medio término en noviembre además clave
para la posibilidad desarrollar una
agenda progresista si rápidamente es
bastante optimista cito textualmente sus
palabras dice en enero habrá una
presencia progresista más fuerte en la
cámara que en cualquier otro momento de
la historia moderna
estamos viendo logros a nivel político a
nivel organizativo por lo que estamos
progresando no digamos que vincule a
esta ola estos nuevos movimientos
sociales con los resultados que espera
de las elecciones de medio término y
concluye esta entrevista diciendo que
los demócratas así como otros partidos
pero centran centrándose en este partido
estado unido dice tienen que elegir son
el partido de la clase trabajadora o el
de la élite continuamos ahora hablando
de eeuu porque un nuevo estudio
realizado esta vez por yougov y decano
me señala que casi la mitad de los
estadounidenses creen que es posible que
estalle una guerra civil en la próxima
década rosa exactamente han salido
distintos estudios digamos investigando
un poco esta cuestión pero nos centramos
en este que digamos concluye el 43% de
la población de eeuu cree que es posible
una guerra civil en los próximos diez
años un pensamiento que está más
extendido entre los republicanos también
dos tercios de la población cree que las
divisiones políticas y la violencia
política ha aumentado desde 2021 un tema
bien delicado vamos a ver ahora a rózsa
y es la situación en china en región
autónoma de xinjiang de los uigures esta
minoría de musulmana en china pues es
que ha sido pues víctima de violaciones
de los derechos humanos también crímenes
de lesa humanidad todo esto recogido en
el más reciente informe publicado ayer
por el alta comisionada de derechos
humanos naciones unidas- michelle
bachelet tras la visita a este
territorio rosa vamos a ver como lo
titula el país una mirada occidental
efectivamente y precisamente como
comentabas en este informe lo publicó la
onu no la oficina por los derechos
humanos minutos antes de que se acabara
el mandato de bachelet como alta
comisionada de este departamento de
naciones unidas lo que puede reflejar en
cierto modo las presiones que ella mismo
ella misma ha denunciado respecto a este
tema tanto cuando visitó xinjiang en
mayo como alrededor de este informe no
ella misma ha declarado y así lo
menciona el país haber recibido
presiones tanto por digamos eeuu por un
lado como por china por el otro no y
rápidamente para ver como lo titula la
prensa china cómo ha reaccionado digamos
a esta declaración de naciones unidas
que considera creíbles y constitutivas
de un delito tan grave como crímenes
contra la humanidad las repetidas
denuncias de violaciones de los derechos
fundamentales de los words básicamente a
esto china a esta acusación en este
informe responde diciendo que al final
es una qué es un documento político que
es un complot antichina y que está
basado en la presunción de culpabilidad
en lugar de la presunción de inocencia
rápidamente rosa para finalizar que dice
el periódico chino 'global times' bien
el discurso un poco que encontramos
muchas veces cuando se tratan estos
temas sensibles de esta moraleja digamos
dice que eeuu debería mirarse ante el
espejo antes de acusar a otros países de
violaciones de los derechos humanos y
que precisamente pues ésta es una
campaña que está intentando digamos
rebajar la influencia internacional de
china rosa como siempre gracias por toda
la información mañana con más de revista
de prensa vamos a profundizar en ese
tema con este primer invitado del día